ah okay so Robson this one I just
happened to be driving by okay say well
actually he specifically said you know
for the last episode of the of the
second season you really want to come in
they really want to talk about that
episode and so we have the crossroads of
destiny and yeah shit shit exactly shit
goes down ya know this was like the sort
of like so I think I'm I said before
it's winning like Game of Thrones kind
of you know except it feels Game of
Thrones like half but people be dead you
know like yeah I'm mostly all of them
private the Avatar would be a just
enough and conscious or imprisoned in
this show and then killed out there but
make it look like they're gonna leave
and then chop their head offers nothing
yeah I think your hopes for a killing
spree ending aren't really gonna
materialize oh man one that'd just be a
twist just like last episode just simply
like apparently they do
everybody dies and Aang is the only one
left standing crying over the like world
that's been burnt to a crisp what have I
done there's some slits his neck I'm
like Superman right there just like you
saved us so well anyway okay so we got
this episode first of all I mean just
you know bad news is coming with as
previously an avatar it's like if you
die all the avatars will be destroyed
and we will not be able to come back and
it's like no pressure
oh that's that's a great leave in like
I'm sure everything's gonna be fine in
this episode so so we pretty much have
and her her gang had pretty much taken
over the earth Kingdom through actually
I wonder if they were referencing how
when she was saying you know destroy
from the inside instead of the outside
referencing how the drill was taken down
pretty much how I took it down I wanted
that sort of the idea that she yeah well
that's how they tell you that down maybe
we should use our the same ideology here
yeah I think so and what a great reveal
too because when they showed up in the
in Sookie's armor
just where is Sookie by the way that's
the great that's the great question
which is what makes this whole thing
really creepy is she's never
acknowledged and you know it's not
enough oh well they forgot about her
this whole time I've been watching the
show and this this last episode this
season as I go on into third season I'm
just like where is Sookie what I was
like this can't be good I didn't about
it I didn't think about it because on
the cover of the second season you see
like him holding her what really should
I be bi marry he's the one having a hard
time regardless she's already like
they're gonna be the item and it's like
she's in what two episodes and then
she's like out of commission for the
second solution it was a very Star Wars
poster kind of cover to this season this
make sense so yeah I have no idea where
the hell she is um I you can only assume
it's bad the last time we saw her was
her in Azula yeah and they have her
clothes obviously and I find it you know
I I find it way way more creepier that
we don't know what happened to her
yeah so pretty much you have this big
fights going on yet this wonderful line
where she double crosses or triple
crosses whatever the second-in-command
of the earth Kingdom and knows the part
where I double-cross you attack hurt
nobody even tries and she's like they're
just waiting to see who will win who do
you think is gonna win and he just knows
he's lost because if they try and add to
a battle she will whoop him and just by
looking into her eyes he has that betta
sweat like no but she has my moves
calculated all out she's got me and when
he bows down and says you beat me my own
game got that fucking awesome lawyer
she's like you weren't even at Slayer
just like totally surrender he's like no
no this isn't happening is like i-i've
lost it reminds me of that movie hero
with Jet Li where they're sitting right
across from each other and they know
that both of them are so good their
moves and that he's trained so well that
no matter what he does he can't win cuz
he just tries to go for a sword he will
die right now it's
he just reads instantly this will not
end well yeah yeah just staring and
Rises like she will kill me so it's a
great insight into azula's character too
because she trusts nobody and therefore
she's able to out scheme the schemer
because she trusts nobody and this
there's a payoff to this later so which
i think is just great as the series goes
on what I love is I'll say in the
episode before how I mean she even lets
herself you know it get caught you know
like whatever the earthbenders have her
and she's like what do you wonder you
know if you wanna strike a deal nothing
gonna deal with you and it's like you
know she could kill these people like in
half a second but she's playing weak and
dumb and it's such a great scene with
your wife when she has that little smirk
and it's just man what a good villain is
she's like what 13 fucka day what a
great girl it's a little I think her and
Zuko are a little older than Katara and
Sokka well your anything never quite
figured out their exact ages I know I
think Aang's the youngest and they were
hanging tough and what's the youngest
and Azula looks like second hole isn't
and Zuko probably oldest look no does
doesn't she call him little burglar no
no no she's a big brother no she's the
younger one yeah their ages don't matter
that much to me I mean it's really well
I think it's yeah so I mean you got this
going on yep there's great big fight at
the end and finally surrenders for lack
of better way of putting it caring about
Katara I see she's in danger but
realizes he has to block her out of his
mind he has to like over he has to let
go of the care for her in order to
really give into the Avatar state and
sure enough what happens he gets axed
off and she comes in to save the day I'm
wondering that's gonna come in later if
it's like you know oh by the way yeah I
totally blocked you out of my mind and
said you didn't matter to achieve the
Avatar state um thanks for using your
magic water that could only be used on
one person and totally bringing me back
from the dead and saving me and those
the entire world thanks
I mean that's like dude yeah there is
harsh what you really think about that
he finally have to put her out of his
mind and like just sacrifice caring
about her and sure enough what saves the
day is her caring about him and her
making the sacrifices whole this whole
theme about what the avatar demands
versus what Aang needs to be emotionally
satisfied carries on into the third
season yes I hear he's on really into
the finale
cuz the finale basically addresses a lot
of that which is well if I have to
completely detach you know does that
make me sort of a robot do I have to do
exactly what the Guru is tell her what
the avatar is of day you know there
really is a great day it is addressed
and I think this sets that up and very
very adult themes like that's a very
tough thing to address it's how much do
you detach and how much is needed and
how far is too far how little is too
little and again the and it really put
you in a circumstance where you're
really questioning this like yeah what
was the right move or what wasn't the
right move here because he does get
killed and ultimately it's her
connection with him that brings him back
and her sacrifice really is you could
use that water for anyway she almost
killed minuto there's a huge sort of
Taoist element to this whole show which
is things seem to work out and this is
always the the clever thing it's always
seems to balance yeah this is always a
clever thing I thought two Star Wars the
original trilogy I'm not gonna get into
the prequels but it runs on that same
concept particularly in Jedi and Empire
Strikes Back which is mistakes happen
and yet still somehow through those
mistakes good things come out of it that
you can never exactly predict what the
future is going to hold and so all of
these things keep happening and
technically you would say well maybe
aang made the wrong move but it all ends
up somehow working out like they make
something out of it
they keep persevering it's adapting and
working with your environment and bad
things come your way and work with it
yeah make it's like swimming you can
either struggle against the current or
kind of work with it and stay afloat so
yeah now with that said
the one scene that we talked about this
a little bit before that it was kind of
torn on I'm still kind of torn on is
Zuko's turn at the end when he switches
back pretty much to the dark side and
for me I don't mind that he turns back
and I could see it happening what
bothers me is that they spend so much
time showing him they show him getting
sick through the change of a letting go
of the avatar they show the duality
happening in this great dream sequence
with these two dragons they show him
finally coming to grits and being
actually happy just sweeping the floors
and making tea I mean it doesn't look
like he's faking he seems legitimately
happy and he's even willing to go out to
the sisters say no I can't run forever I
got a you know I got to start my new
life I have to you know be Who I am now
and I can't have this haunting me and
within a millisecond it seems to turn
back and I'm not against the turn I'm
against the fact that it was so quick
after we showed such a long process the
other way and I wasn't sure how to feel
about that I didn't blow okay I mean
Dante Bosco was a great voice actor so
when I say this is not criticizing his
voice acting when I saw those episodes
originally where he had become nice you
know good morning uncle it's a great day
and that I didn't believe him for a
second and I'm not entirely convinced
that the show is telling you know you
have to believe this that he suddenly
really wants to be a villager I think
that performance and I could be talking
completely out of my ass here and you
know he could come out at some point
talking about the show and I could be
proven completely wrong I think some of
that performance is the character of
Zuko trying to convince himself that
this is what he wants I don't think he
ever fully believed it every time I see
those episodes he is so nice to such a
degree and it's such a turnaround that I
always was sitting there in the back my
head going you know I think he's still
very confused I think he wants to
believe this this is somebody who is
being handed this gift and he wants to
grab it and he really desperately wants
a this is what
this is what I really want but deep down
inside he's like something's still not
right and that is his character arc the
whole way through it is always something
is still not right and it's about but
what have shown that they're so good at
showing just the little twinges or the
little turns or the little frowns or
smirking so that don't you think they
what's that cuz I mean every time it
leaves on a shot with him he is smiling
and he is for a P but they sing it to me
it seems like it's building up that
everything's gonna come crumbling down
he's happy and of course things are
gonna come crumbling down why would he
those show that when there's nothing
else on the table to make him believe
otherwise in that moment see what
happens in this episode is she gives him
Zuma Azula gives him the offer and says
you can come back you know we can get
the avatar
you know this is your chance to restore
your honor before that that wasn't on
the table when he accepts this and says
I will live life as a villager which is
something that eventually he seemed to
come around but he's clearly
uncomfortable with it for a number of
years so it's almost the whole season so
that when he makes that turn at the end
to me that was him hitting rock bottom
going why I have no other option on the
table maybe this is my one chance maybe
I'll start to embrace it when she comes
out though and people work like this
they'll they'll accept something and
then you give him that one bit of
temptation like oh it's on the table
again maybe maybe I can do this like
they had blocked it out of mind and that
one thing comes forward and he takes it
well in that see that's the thing and
that's what I was guessing the probably
going for is that even though you're so
committed to something when that you
know he has not been you know making tea
and sweeping floors as long as he has
been chasing you let me put it this way
and when they change happens ok somewhat
agreeing with you here when that change
is offered it and it's made clear even
though it's by Azula which I'm still
like wait she's trying to kill you
several times but when the option is
finally made there and it seems very
real and very physical and can happen
and can actually be delivered to you
that everything you had before it just
fails you and it's almost like a total
relapse to what you had before and it's
like you
and healthy because it's just been in
there longer but if that is the case why
couldn't they show him like go back to
maybe that vision with the Dragons or a
little bit more you see him thinking for
a little bit granted and I'm sure
they're going more for the shock value
of it that he turned but why didn't they
show a little bit more the turmoil of it
because I'll know that to me it really
seemed like he was content with the life
that was finally being handed to him and
he went through that Cygnus and he went
through the dreams and why would they
show that if they didn't want to get
across like he was really really
becoming one with that world and
actually enjoying it because it's an
addiction
the thing about Zuko is if you if you
watch this entire season and look at it
as his wanting to get his honor back
this obsession with getting Aang this is
all an addiction of his and what he does
at the end of the second season is no
different than an alcoholic in a moment
in a low moment turning back to drinking
you know and you could say well I would
you be sober for all this time and then
just go right back drinking um you know
and I part of it you're right I think it
is for shock value you know and I think
that it's much more of a jaw-dropping
moment if you don't drop all the little
hints that maybe he's gonna go back and
I was fine with that again because I
kind of looked at it as it took him so
long to get to that point where he
accepted it that like to me if you
really wanted to to show that you know
he was basically I would have had him if
he was really going to be good
throughout the rest of it do that turn
much earlier where he accepts the
village life much earlier in the season
but it took so long to get there that I
was just thinking yeah I think that was
part of their point is that he's not
really accepting this in the very end he
accepts it cuz he finally hits that
point I have no other out nowhere to
escape you know and nobody had Appa
he had Appa there and he could have
waited for the Avatar to come he had the
Blue Spirit outfit and his uncle came
and said what do you really want what is
it that you really crave and he turns
away and that's when the sickness begins
that's when the dream begins he did
have that option you mean the option to
go back and capture Aang to get the
avatar yeah to regain his honour for the
Fire Nation but the thing is I think he
would still see that's where I think his
uncle's influence comes in you know I
think his uncle was not there he
actually would have done it you know but
that's the BET's the point is I
something was there later to saying Zuko
don't do it don't turn to Azula don't
don't go there I'm he is but I think
there's a difference between they having
up there in concocting an entire giant
plan and knowing the avatars in the
other room the avatars in the other room
yeah I mean that's my point it's like
it's way more immediate you know and the
other thing is particularly in the rest
of the season he seems always in these
sort of situations where there's a
thousand things going on it's the same
whenever he's the Blue Spirit you know
it's like there's a ton of things going
on I think that when you're presented
with the choice between oh you have this
battle going on I found Appa I can do
this you know there's this whole earth
Kingdom conspiracy which he seems to be
aware of you know you're kind of busy
you know in this scenario
there's the Avatar right there you can
go get him like I think that temptation
of just like it's it's gift-wrapped with
a nice bow versus the other one where he
has to really work at it and he has the
time to think well I think in that
moment of panic he just was like I got
to do this well and I will say this
again this is something I bring a bomb
to me the only reason I said before
about talking about this at all is that
this show again has just really really
raised the bar in this I would not be
talking in this great detail usually
about any other family show and I do
realize that's the termes family show
not kids show this is not for kids this
is her family just from a narrative
perspective I mean if you want probably
the ultimate reason it is shock value
but to me that doesn't make it any real
to me that doesn't make it worse for it
because honestly I thought it was such a
great twist that you know I am looking
back on it I just always justified as
yeah I'm not sure I ever fully believed
him anyway so to me
it just makes sense well and again you
you have this you have this long show I
mean it a we know how tough it is I mean
a lot writers do how you know to squeeze
so much into was it 24 minutes yeah and
to have character and to have story and
to give a damn about to have this pacing
and to have this long story go over and
episodic episodes and you know ones are
self-contained
and once I have to continue the story I
mean again to get any of this is very
impressive and even if there is this
moment where I'm Serling and it could
have been done a bit better it's still
fucking impressive and this is still a
really good finale for the second season
yeah it's still a good I mean you just
watch in you just go home it follows the
tradition of I'm not gonna say middle
story syndrome but in particularly I
mean this is the Empire Strikes Back the
second act the series now the real
conflict is say the first is
introduction second is the conflict if
there's the rush of the compliment well
not only what a great second act but if
you're gonna do the Empire Strikes Back
this nail bit I mean when I think about
the second act new locale a conspiracy
the way it ends you know I I really have
expected you know like Aang to just
right away enough of me like don't worry
we'll get him back from that bounty
hunter like it Billy Dee Aang it's
really really they to me it's it's
obvious I don't mean this in the
negative way I don't make everything
enough but it's very clear they watch
Star Wars and were just like yeah we can
do this it's well when the Guru I even
see the last one I'm like you know yes
and Yoda says to Skywalker come back or
you won't learn your training oh I'm
sorry the Guru says to Aang and says
come back you what when you're training
forget your friends you know if they lie
somewhere I mean with this one you have
the character pretty much dead you know
he's brought back but I'm assuming
they're insinuating now that the avatar
state is like kaput
like he's the last one I mean why else
would they show that previously on
element there why would they have that
even in there if he dies the thing I
think think about this all together
you've got the same group of characters
going to a new locale where there is a
conspiracy going on
that can basically undermine their whole
mission you've got a conflict with your
main villains which he loses they all
ride away basically sort of into the
sunset you know worried some of the
cameras are missing going after we had a
wise guru we had and I'm not saying this
in a negative way it's actually a
compliment because I think the original
Star Wars trilogy was brilliant yeah
it's a great day anyway yeah the next
one and that's so many movies you know
there are so many people that rip Star
Wars off and you just feel like yeah you
just ripped Star Wars off there's not
that much you didn't because Star Wars
yeah it here if you haven't brought
anything to the table like this is this
good storytelling yeah this is the best
homage to Empire Strikes Back I have
ever seen like it nailed it it got it
right and it's it's own thing yeah while
it's its own yeah I'm not saying it as a
negative but I'm saying is there is a
definitely clear connection that I think
they're like yeah we're kind of doing
Star Wars with each season you know
particularly seasons two and three
because I've seen all three now so again
not a bad thing but I think you can't
avoid kind of looking at it that way
well I mean you could even say that the
Star Wars trilogies have been doing I
mean they've been doing what other great
trilogy three partners have done it just
means just read any Joseph Campbell book
I mean Lucas was just playing mythical
archetypes oh yeah and I mean this show
does the same thing and there's nothing
wrong with that it's but by the best you
take one example it's still its own
thing yeah it's still its own thing and
it's one of the best examples to how to
really use mythical archetypes and do
something in a similar vein to Star Wars
while being its own thing but there but
structurally speaking it is very similar
you know the way the whole plot shaped
out in the second season to Empire
Strikes Back and in some ways you know
the third season reminds me of Jedi and
some of the things it does so again not
a bad thing I think that makes it cooler
myself I don't you know if it was a lame
ripoff of Star Wars I'd be like this
sucks but you know to me and it may be
unintentional they may be like well we
weren't intentionally doing that but you
know it's such a part of the culture now
that you know you may not be able to
avoid it and I need Star Wars was
ripping off Tolkien as well so yeah but
Tolkien had his
it goes back to that yeah this goes back
to the dawn of time so yes so bottom
line good good ending to a good season I
guess the moral of this whole season is
just the earth Kingdom sucks stay the
fuck away from the earth King come and
fucking pass it's not cloud city don't
go so uh yeah I love the second season
can't wait to see the third season and
that's coming up next so we'll see you
there